عشان تتخيلوا ماذا يمكن ان يحدث للعالم
اذا ارتفعت درجه حراره الارض بهذه
المعدلات المخيفه
احلكم الى طبعا في مئات الدراسات لكن
احيلكم الى دراسه يعني اعتقد انها تستحق
الاهتمام وهي دراسه قديمه الدراسه دي
اجريت في اكتوبر 2003 لماذا اشير الى هذه
الدراسه وليس دراسات اخرى احدث منها اولا
عشان اقول لحضراتكم ان الظاهره كانت
معلومه لدى العلماء والحكومات منذ زمن
بعيد ثانيا الدراسه دي اللي اقراها هي
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه العلماء الذين
اجروا هذه الدراسه بيحظوا باحترام بين
العلماء المختصين في قضايا البيئه والمناخ
في سبب اخر يعطي اهميه خاصه لهذه الدراسه
هو ان من اشرف عليها هو اندرو ماشل واندرو
ماشل ده استراتيجست مهم هو توفى في 2019
لكنه كان مؤثرا جدا في السياسات التي
تتخذها الولايات المتحده على مدار اربع
عقود من سنه 49 ولمده 40 سنه متتاليه
اندروباشل عهد بالدراسه الى مجموعه من
العلماء واعدوا دراسه انا حاطط لحضراتكم
رابط هذه الدراسه في مراجع الحلقه الدراسه
بتتحدث عن النتائج التي يمكن ان تحدث
للعالم ولولايات المتحده على وجه التحديد
اذا ما حدث تغير مفاجئ في المناخ والدراسه
بتقول انه السائد لدى العلماء انه الكره
الارضيه بتشهد تغير في المناخ نعم لكن هذا
التغير اللي هو بياخد اشكال متطرفه مختلفه
ارتفاع في درجه الحراره او انخفاض تدريجي
وبالتالي العالم خصوصا الدول الغنيه قادره
على التاقلم معه ماذا يحدث لو حاله تغير
مفاجئ في درجات الحراره
والدراسه بتقول نحن نسلم في البدايه ان
السيناريو الذي نتناوله اقل احتمالا لكنه
ليس خياليا يعني من غير المحتمل بالضروره
ان يحدث او احتمال امر ليس واردا بالضروره
لكنه مبني على
دلائل علميه ومقدمات علميه وليس خيالا
خلاصه الدراسه بتتوقع انه خلال من 15 الى
20 سنه اتدرس اجريت في 2003 وبالتالي هو
بيتكلم على 2020 2021 السنوات التي نعيش
فيها الان بيتوقع ان العالم سوف يشهد
تغيرا في درجات الحراره ما بين دول تشهد
انخفاض اكثر من المعتاد في درجات الحراره
ودول سوف تشهد ارتفاعا وجفافا اكثر من
المعتاد طبعا نصيبنا احنا في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والعالم العربي الجفاف وارتفاع
درجات الحراره الزائد
وبيتوقع انه هينجم عن هذا التغير اضطرابات
عنيفه جدا في الانشطه الاقتصاديه في
الحياه البحريه والحياه البريه وفي
الزراعه والمراعي الى اخره وبالتالي تنجم
عنه تغيرات كبيره الدراسه بتتحدث عن
سيناريوهات كثيره لكن اعطيكم انا امثله
قليله اختصارا للوقت بيقول تخيلوا ماذا
يمكن ان يحدث لما مثلا تقل هبوط الامطار
في بلد مثل استراليا
بتمثل مصدر مهم للبروتين الحيواني لكل دول
العالم اذا انخفضت سقوط الامطار هيقل نسبه
نمو العشب والكلا الذي تتغذى عليه الماشيه
وبالتالي هتكون الماشيه عاجزه عن الغذاء
هتقل احجامها اوزنها وبالتالي سوف يؤثر
ذلك على سوق اللحوم في العالم كله وسوف
يؤثر ايضا على سوق الالبان وكل المنتجات
التي تؤخذ من الالبان
يتحدث عما يمكن ان يحدث بين الدول
المتشتاء على نفس البحار لما تتاثر الحياه
البحريه ويصبح هناك صراع على حقوق الصيد
وادى مثل بينما يمكن ان يحرض بين اسبانيا
والبرتغال على سبيل المثال تحدث عن
سيناريو اكثر يعني
رعبا لما الدول تجد نفسها بتعاني من جفاف
او فساد للنشاط الاقتصادي نتيجه للسقيع او
الحر الشديد بقول تخيلوا كيف يمكن ان تفكر
بلد مثل اليابان بيتعرض الى تغيرات مناخيه
بتتمثل في اغراق لشواطئه والى اتلاف
لنشاطه الاقتصادي ورغبته في ان هو
ونضب في المياه العذبه
ويسعى للحصول على طاقه لا يملكها
للحصول على
مصادر ومحطات بناء محطات لتحليه مياه
المحيط وهو يرى ان جارته اللي هي روسيا
عندها فائض كبير في الطاقه وفائض كبير في
المياه نفس الشيء اوروبا الشرقيه قد تجد
نفسها عاجزه عن اطعام شعوبها بينما روسيا
بلد غني بالطاقه غني بالمياه ولديه عدد
السكان محدود ويتناقص هذه الشعوب سوف تتجه
في شكل هجرات جماعيه الى روسيا تحدث
اضطرابات في روسيا البلد العسكري القوي
تحدث اضطرابات بين اليابان او دول اخرى مع
الروس الدول التي تملك القدره على الدفاع
سوف تسعى الى الدفاع النفسيه بالقوه
العسكريه الدول الضعيفه سوف تسعى الى
التسلح لمهاجمه الدول التي تملك مصادر
اكبر من الطاقه والغذاء والمياه
يتحدث ايضا عن صراعات كثيره وارده في 200
حوض نهر حول العالم دراسه بتقول ان في 200
حوض نهر زي حوض النيل مثلا كل حوض بتتشاطئ
في مجموعه من الدول ومنها حوض النيل التي
تحدث عنه التقرير اللي بيضم التسع دول
متشاطئه عليه بيقول ان هذه الدول سوف
تتصارع فيما بينها للحصول على اكبر نصيب
ممكن من المياه نتيجه الجفاف الذي يضرب
هذه الدول وذكر نهر النيل باعتباره احد
مصادر الصرع المحتمله خلال السنوات
المقبله والدراسه اذكركم كانت في 2003 وهو
ما حدث على العموم حتى لا نغرق في
التفاصيل الدراسه قالت كلمتين مهمين جدا
قالت ان العالم هيتخذ
تجاه التغيرات المناخيه المفاجئه نوعين من
الاستعدادات سياسات هجوميه وسياسات دفاعيه
الدول الغنيه اللي عندها وفره سوف تقوم
ببناء سوف اسعى ان تحيط انفسها باسوار
تاخذ اشكال مختلفه علشان تمنع المهاجرين
من الدول الاخرى من الهجوم على حدودها هذه
الدول الهدف اساسي من هذه الاسوار اللي
هتاخد اشكال مختلفه هي حمايه حدودها
الدول اللي هي اقل حظا واللي بتعاني من
نقص في مواردها من المياه والغذاء والطاقه
سوف تسعى للعدوان على الدول المجاوره
العدوان ده بياخذ شكل هجرات جماعيه مربكه
او شكل عدوان عسكري والدراسه بتتوقع انه
دول كثيره سوف تسعى لامتلاك السلاح النووي
مش للدفاع عن نفسها ولكن لتمكينها من
العدوان على دول اخرى بهدف الحصول على
موارد اضافيه لاطعام شعوبها دراسه بتقول
ان حروب الناتجه عن التغير المناخي وهي
عباره مهمه جدا سوف تكون حروب سرفايفل
حروب للبقاء وليس من اجل الدين ولا من اجل
الناشونال برايد اللي هو يعني المجد
القومى بلدين ما
كلام الدراسه وهو طبعا ابقي سرا لابقي سرا
لانه زي ما قلت لحضراتكم جورج بوش الابن
لم يكن يؤمن او لم يكن يتبنى قضايا المناخ
فابقي على الدراسه سرا طب كيف عرفت لانه
بعض وسائل الاعلام ومنها حصلت على نسخه من
هذه الدراسه وبالتالي اخذت طريقها الى
وسائل الاعلام